Если вы не теряете друзей значит вы не
растёте вот вообще кто такой глан
Калиевич я всю жизнь работал на
госслужбе и я вообще без госслужбе Сея
не представлял если ты в своём
сообществе тебя всегда поддержат Блин ну
ты вообще ошибался вообще всё не так
если ты растёшь у тебя всё время растёт
окружение масштаб людей которые тебя
окружают моя супруга она благодарна что
я вообще в кайн клуб попал вообще ты
стал другим человеком классная
[музыка]
Метрика друзья Добрый день Сегодня мы
начинаем очередной выпуск нашего гемба
подкаста напомню про формат нашего МБО
подкаста М - это перевод с японского
слова место где происходит события либо
место где принимается решение по
корневой проблеме или корневой причине а
выявлению корневой причины для того
чтобы её устранить поэтому звучит и
переводится это слово таким образом Но
идея которая стоит за всем этим
заключается в том что я на этом формате
собираю людей которые подчеркну являются
Но которые достигли определённых успехов
в своих сферах жизни и они могут быть из
различных сфер и мы обсуждаем какую-то
тему которая актуальна обществу То есть
это как посиделка на кухне только мы
говорим на определённую тему мы не
говорим обо всём подряд мы говорим на
конкретную определённую тему и сегодня
тема нашего гемба подкаста Я думаю она
актуальна многие Сегодня говорят о том
что насколько важно окружение в росте
человека
Понятно Я имею в виду не физический рост
а духовный профессиональный Там и так
далее И вот когда если мы говорим Как
вырасти человеку вырасти Как вырастить
его бизнес или профессиональный рост
или там рост по социальным сетям его
рост популярности Славы и так далее
влияния и так далее то там много
факторов и один из главных факторов -
это окружение которое находится вокруг
этого человека и которое либо
способствует росту этого че Либо
наоборот тормозит Этот рост и сегодня я
хотел бы поговорить как раз о том как
нам максимально эффективно использовать
своё окружение Как нам определить какое
окружение способствует нашему росту А
какое нет И вообще каким самому надо
быть чтобы способствовать росту других
людей и чтобы другие люди хотели
помогать вам то есть мы сегодня
обсуждаем всё по поводу того как вырасти
и при этом Как вырасти с помощью своего
окружения и как максимум выжать из
своего окружения и покинуть то окружение
которое вас не развивает итак по
традиции у нас идёт представление мы э
даём как правило Ну давайте сегодня вот
вот так каждый У нас гость
представляется самостоятельно
рассказывать о себе краткую
информацию и поедем дальше Добрый день
Меня зовут Нура Ахмед Жана Беков Я из
Астаны с астанинское н клуба А я сам
юрист по образованию много лет
проработал государственной службы в
квази государственном секторе Но после
того как в мою жизнь вошёл Кан клуб и
маргулан кович я это дело а остановил и
перешёл в Сферу частного бизнеса у меня
компания в сфере логистики перевозки
грузов уже 3 года мы работаем в этой с
сфери международных переводов Угу Ты то
есть ты человек который эволюционировал
с госслужащего в бизнесмена Да кстати
говоря Это такой был непростой опыт и
могу много на эту тему Да кстати
история Нура ахмета тоже интересна В чём
потому что у меня есть несколько
учеников которые из госслужбы перешли в
бизнес и там Прямо целый большой блок
Пласт проблем в отношениях со своим
окружением и мы как раз сегодня об этом
тоже поговорим И это будет я уверен
интересно для тех кто Находится на
госслужбе и подумывает о том как сменить
сферу своей
деятельности Меня зовут Николай Пак я
Медиа предприниматель сооснователь
YouTube канала мы вот сделали недавно
этот канал сейчас у нас
600.000 Медиа предприниматели занимаюсь
в основном производством медиапроектов в
осном это видео проекты телевидение
YouTube кино вот в этой сфере Ну кстати
Николай ты до этого
был кинопродюсер
да сейчас занима
всеи
кони фокус у меня не на ней ээ Вот и
теперь вот YouTube Я вижу в нём как бы и
классно что я сейчас на самом большом
как мне кажется и самом влиятельной
YouTube канале в Казахстане Ну вот мы
вторые по
влиянию Класс Класс сама реклама
допускается
айн коротко Понятно Меня зовут Анжелика
Ну я красивая женщина просто Поучу в
начале Да бесспорно чаль
сама
предприниматель немного блогер и меценат
если говорить про бизнес то мы работаем
в сфере электротехники поставляем и
производим кабельно-проводниковой
продукцию розетки выключатели в общем
всё что нужно для электромонтажа как я
шучу несём свет и энергию людям в нашей
стране Так классно ла если говорить
необычно почти религиозный СГА
религиозный да
наша миссия но а Моё хобби влечение -
это конечно страничка в Instagram
посвящённая современному искусству
называется Анжелика Иар где мы с
подругой легко просто доступно говорим
на такую непонятную для большинства
людей тему как современное искусство
класс Кстати два два разрыва шаблона
первое женщина которая занимается
электрическими кабелями электротехникой
а второе то что с другой стороны другой
полюс - это искусство простыми сло вами
интересно Всем привет Меня зовут Н Я
являюсь прожект менеджером казо клуба
вот Ребята только что говорили о Каз
клубе хочу рассказать вообще что это
такое Это такое Международное сообщество
собственников среднего бизнеса которые
нацелены на рост бизнеса и на развитие
себя я бы я бы добавил не прожект
менеджер Чтобы проще было понимать ке
руководитель ка клуба по сути поэтому
она с самого начала У истоков Казин
клуба и она я специально её пригласил
сед на это г подкаст потому что мы будем
обсуждать окружение и через её руки
проходят сотни бизнесменов историй
бизнеса и она видит кто растёт кто не
растёт и почему и Как растёт Все
лют спасибо большое так да Всем привет
Меня зовут Санжар Мне 35 я се платформы
Гула сембаева образовательной платформы
Я тоже эволюционировал из одной сферы
деятельности в образования и уже 3 года
нахожусь в команде глан левича И вот мы
развиваем этот образовательный проект
создаём новые продукты и Ну вот приносим
пользу обществу Санжар он работал до
этого в Москве
и его деятельность никак не была связана
с образованием и социальными сетями и
так далее и он за последние 3 года очень
сильно эволюционировал вообще в другую
сферу другую отрасль Ну я просто доволен
как он сейчас развивается И это
тоже одно из заслуг это благодаря тому
окружению в котором он находится Итак
давайте перейдём к самой теме смотрите
каждый из вас эволюционировал каждый из
вас вырос но я вообще считаю что
Наверное трудно найти человека который
не эволюционировал бы потому что мы всё
равно ходили в школу потом закончили
школу пошли в университет это тоже
эволюция потом женились или Замуж вышли
это тоже эволюция вот эти все изменения
человека не могу сказать что в лучшую
сторону
Но вообще любая эволюция человека она
может происходить только в двух
траекториях первоя либо человек растёт и
процветает либо деградирует и умирает
другого варианта в этой жизни нет это не
только у людей Кстати это и у животных
также и у растений точно также ты либо
процветает там женится замуж уходит
купил дом Купил машину сделал стал
бизнесменом и так далее он
эволюционирует а любая эволюция - это
рост
А если это не деградация конечно так вот
каждый из вас прошёл определённый путь и
меня именно интересует На этом гемо
подкасте не то что я собрал самых крутых
людей крутых людей много да А меня
интересует тема Я уверен Вас тоже всех
это интересует как вот мы обычные люди
эволюционируем и какой у нас при этом
опыт и Сегодня хотелось бы именно больше
акцент дать на то как выжимать из своего
окружения максимум И как избавиться от
старого окружения Почему я говорю
избавиться от старого окружения это
грубо звучит не всегда надо избавляться
сразу забегая вперёд скажу
но я прочитал недавно очень хорошую
фразу которая гласит так если вы не
теряете друзей значит вы не
растёте Если вы не теряете друзей значит
вы не растёте у меня в своё
время ребята из клуба задавали вопрос и
писали прямо много а по этой теме Я даже
делал целый отдельный пост Я помню Да да
И там мне задавали вопрос морлан корич
Как только я с вами связался я начал
расти и мне говорит стало неинтересно
общаться со своими друзьями да это есть
такое мне стало неинтересно общаться со
своими друзьями и я чувствую больше
одиночество Потому что когда я прихожу
говорит Ну они разговаривают там о
политике о женщинах в бане там то всё я
чувствую про драки ещё часто вспоминаю
драки драки про прошлое говорит я
понимаю насколько это бездарное время
провождение и начинаю отдаляться и
чувствую определённое одиночество и вот
я написал специально большой пост о том
который так и звучит Что произойдёт
Когда будет расти ваша эффективность и
Давайте начнём Вот именно с этой Что
произошло с вашей
средой в которой вы были раньше до
эволюции и вот эта среда ваши друзья
окружение коллеги они сохранились или
нет вообще как выстраивались отношения
происходили конфликты определённые или
нет Вот этот момент я хотел бы
[музыка]
услышать друзья партнёр нашего
сегодняшнего выпуска шины йн шины йн -
это высококачественные комфортные шины
для любых дорог созданные по японской
технологии я сам уже больше полугода
пользуюсь этими шинами Они износостойкие
они управляемые и они малошумные Поэтому
если вы подбираете качественные шины
Обратите внимание на этот бренд шины
[музыка]
н так кого
начнём Ну давайте я начну Да потому что
у меня э история произошла недавно ты
больше всего кивал головой
поэтому
заслужил
хозя ирия в том
став пото что мне Лось я пря получал
удовольствие потому что у тебя есть
ресурс у тебя есть влияние У тебя есть
возможность что-то таком на Большом
плане
изменить но прошло определённое
количество времени я стал задумываться
уже о будущем своём уже время дети
растут и так далее и в это
время опять-таки про неслучайности у
меня попадает история
про лекции слушать потом Сам пришёл
трекером на платформу мача Я уже 3 года
трекер на этой платформе и благодаря
этому я попал в окружение людей которые
уже что-то делают сами и у меня началось
в голове трас я думаю ну обычные люди
Угу что-то Ну и причём ещё эго же у тебя
есть я был топ-менеджером тогда в
компании я смотрю на них и ты думаешь я
же больше знаю больше умею там больше у
меня каких-то возможностей Но в
отличие от меня они уже делают что-то и
у них очень крутые
и в какой-то истории меня зацепило это
что я вижу Что люди что-то делают и
добиваются причём Ты понимаешь что они
не хуже и не лучше тебя но у них есть
результаты у них есть будущее Ну я бы
сказал будущее есть у всех просто они
контролируют своё будущее больше
контролирует своё будущее да да да И это
же сфера вот самый больной момент
перехода из госслужбы в частно - это
страх потери вот какого-то чёткого
гарантированного будущего понятного тебе
наступит пятое число будет зарплата угу
вот и история про моя история про
окружение то что я увидел что можно
делать да страхи есть Ну О'кей это
нормальная история что это должно быть
это нормальная история в ко А вот смотри
у тебя получается эволюция произошла до
того то есть сначала а давай так А ты
работал в госслужбе потом вошёл в
окружение а потом поменял либо ты
поменял госслужбу на бизнес а потом
пришёл в окружение наоборот сначала в
окружение Я
попал благодаря окружению я увидел людей
которые То есть ты нашу экосистему
пришёл ещё работая госслужащей Да я был
на госслужбе я работал я ещё год работал
на госслужбе А и именно окружение
способствовало именно окружение Только
благодаря ему потому что у меня не было
мысле вообще менять работу уходить с Глу
у меня вообще таких мыслей не я работал
и у меня всё отлично там получалось Я
получал уважение приоритеты там вот это
внешние все элементы призна ня бы я
считал себя очень крутым в этой и все
считали меня крутым но я увидел что есть
люди у которых есть будущее Я понял что
ну как бы вот э история про будущее у
меня оно есть понятное какое-то но есть
будущее гораздо круче моего и есть люди
которые это делают это обычные люди для
меня бизнесмены были какие-то всё равно
необычные люди какими особыми слами
отдельный кла они живут по каким-то
правилам у них какие-то свои идеи свои
мысли
да да дано это Удивительная история что
он в качестве госслужащего Да попал в
клуб это же Ну мне кажется наверно часто
Да я трекером прил Не ну у нас есть
такие истории У нас есть такие истории А
здесь Давайте попытаемся разложить сам
процесс получается
а первое переходу из одной сферы в
другую противо противодействует что
страх раз второе - Это неправильное
представление о людях другой сферо то
есть неправильное представление о
бизнесменах и так далее третье благодаря
сообществу тому что ты нырнул сюда Ты
понял во-первых что это не Волшебники и
Не боги горски обжигают что ты тоже это
можешь да и ты понял что здесь ничего
страшного нет в принципе тебя поддержит
и так далее да да И это вот про Взаимно
пление потому что там ещё ещё один блок
это про знание Угу То есть когда люди ты
в одном кругу И они начинают делить
своми историями и они говорят как они их
решили Ты понимаешь что проблемы это
нормально Ты уже перестаешь их бояться
потому что никто из этого не делает
какую-то ужасную
Трагедию Да продажи упали но я сейчас
вот так буду делать и Окей там у меня
сотрудники уволился весь отдел но я
сейчас вот так сделаю и окей Для меня
эта история знаете Это веры в будущее я
верю него я его
бом дава
именно по этой теме пройдёмся как
окружение оказало влияние на то чтобы ну
эволюционировать чтобы у нас было влево
вправо мальчик девочка влево
направо ну мне наверно в этом плане
знаете немножко повезло Ну ты молодая
потому что
молодым
молом воз потом
яве там уже было такое окружение таких
включенных ребят которые там до 5:00
утра учатся у нас библиотека кру
суточная была И вот делают речи задают
вопросы там выходят на митинги да то
есть это такая продвинутая классная
молодёжь и ты когда смотришь на неё ты
хо ты ты думаешь Блин я тоже я тоже хочу
быть такой я Я тоже в этом хочу
участвовать А потом в моей и вот в этой
всей истории я так варилась то мо моей
жизни появился кайн клуб и он тоже
перевернул моё сознание в том плане что
у меня раньше было такое мышление Да что
вот ты работаешь там до пти Да вот как
Рахмет говорит и потом дальше отдыхаешь
А я пришла в кайн клуб я смотрю никто не
хочет отдыхать взрослые дядьки Да
тётеньки я и вот кто-то там в 61 садится
на шпагат например да ни фига се Да вот
шо Махана Вот она сейчас хочет там
кто-то вот другие резиденты они начинают
там кто-то строит бизнес и они
бесконечно учат
все наши встречи Это обсуждение идей
планирования вообще всего и вот ты в
этом окружении находишься ты думаешь
блин оказывается Ну жизнь - это
бесконечно бесконечное развитие вот у
меня вот такой вот Инсайт был именно с
клубом
иже вот смотрите сразу я буду как бы
чуть-чуть
резюмировать то что с вами происходило
получается вот важно момент который я
очень часто говорю когда вот
родители особенно говорят в какую школу
отдать детей я всегда мой совет Я говорю
отдавайте не в школу а отдавайте в среду
не имеет значения В некоторых
государственных школах среда супер там
все заточены на рост на развитие и так
далее и так далее вот яркий пример Кена
она закончила Назарбаев университет и
соответственно там среда была суперская
и она тебе сразу дала хороший толчок и
другой вопрос тепер как на тебя
кода при з те слом учи надо всю
жи яма всё закончила как Дума ВС буду
кайфовать всю жизнь ВС жизнь оказывается
оказывается всю жиз это
классно сечас кайфуешь тепер от этого
Мне кажется вот то что вы уже в принципе
как-то обозначили вот этой позиции
ученика или позиции человека который
Думает что он всё знает Ну это вот это
был мой случай мне 45 лет и до 40 лет
ээ всё чего я добивался я действовал из
стимула Ну то есть мне ну там 18 лет я
женился у меня появился ребёнок мне надо
было доказать что я взрослый там и
поэтому я там начинал там ну добиваться
каких-то цели потом там не знаю в
подростком возрасте я приезжаю и мне
получается 13 лет Я живу в Алмате я
когда-то хотел жить на на новой площади
свечки вот мне надо было этого добиться
машину купить Ну Понимаете вот потом я
там обанкротился развёлся Мы вдвоём с с
дочерью жили у меня было я пообещал что
она будет за границей жить а у меня вот
банкротство там долги и я как бы
добивался этого это был Стимул то есть
вот и в какой-то момент у меня было
такой момент когда она Вот Закончила и
как раз пандемия началась и всё короче
ну у меня же вот такие краткосрочные
цели как бы да Ну вот тебя толкает твоё
эго или что-то И всё И я не знал что
делать Вот как раз тогда я кстати ваше
видео с четвёртого раза на юбе о бес
цели конн планирование как основа
счастливой жизни как называется оно
такое трудное восприятие я четвёртого
раза тогда посмотрел и увидел ну как
бы ну тогда сейчас трудно назвать это
миссией Но тогда так какие-то ориентиры
миссии условно говоря я проанализировал
свою как бы жизнь понял От чего я
вообще-то счастлив бывал Оказывается это
не деньги Оказывается это вот такой вот
вместе с командой идём что-то такое
мутим потом понял окажется что У мня
получилось вот в этом
[музыка]
продюс было это потому что я полно вде
на своём кабриолете едил все люди
смеялись надо мной У меня не было другой
машины только калет остался После
предыдущего бизнеса не калет удобно же
мешки
закидывать мешки мешки с луком раз на
заднее сиденье из машины не буду
выходить в любом месте остановился
магазин сразу прода Ну может быть но
было дико Конечно вот но и вот после
этого я понял вот что как сказать После
этого я думаю что это был этап такой
мотивации и вот после того как я вот
получается ещё не было кайзен клуба Это
же было первое наставничество Я же самый
первый самый старый старожил я был самый
первый Вот который попал вот эту
двадцатку которые пришли к вам
наставничество с чего всё начало Ну мне
так кажется с этого началось Вот и с
этого момента у меня вот я уже стал
двигаться как бы от мотивации но И что
самое важное Мне кажется что я принял
позицию ученика Я понял что оказывается
я вообще ничего не знаю оказывается маке
сразу как-то пробил с первым же Зума он
мне сказал это вообще не занимайся этим
эти большой рыбы не поймаешь там и все
мои как бы все мои мысли Вот И после
этого я понял что если ты позиция
ученика если у тебя как бы цель
постоянное развитие то нужны ну как бы
все инструменты там у вас учиться было
классное окружение и я думаю например
например знания давали нам вы Угу А вот
смена мышления вроде бы тоже с вашей
подачей но процентов на 50 это
происходило фактор время и окружение мы
находились в этом окружении Ну и все с
разной скоростью меняли мышление
понимаете это не произошло там после вот
такого урока маке нам сказал и мы такие
Ага всё я видел это по моим друзьям
которых я сейчас могу назвать друзьями
что это происходило у всех с разной
скоростью как бы время и
вот время и вот это окружение оно вот
меняет мышление вот такой какой-то такой
рецепт и сейчас Теперь ты подходишь в
том числе к старым друзьям Ну вот с
точки зрения эффективности честно говоря
может быть немножко Прагматично Но вот я
бы
мы да потому что это отдельный блок
вопросов
кото насчёт старого окружения что с ним
стало и так
далее если кратко резюмировать
получается первое до этого ты больше жил
не осознанной жизнью А жил больше жизнью
когда реактивной тебе надо что-то срочно
сделать Ты для этого делаешь в какой-то
момент ты понял что
надо вки цели находить какую миссию для
себя определять и ставить Большие цели
это второй момент на основе этого ты
решил купить наставничество Да я после
вашего видео понял что нужна миссия и
вот предназначение сво нет до этого
получается на основе этого ты понял что
нужно быть в позиции ученика и отложить
своё эго что я уже крутой в чём-то Да
вот это интересно получается прежде чем
прийти в какое-то сообщество нужно
оставить своё эго за дверями иначе Если
человек не готов учиться то бесполезно
заходить в сообщество вот ещ Смотрите
если вы хотите попасть в развивающую
сообщество или развивающее окружение то
оставляйте своё эго за порогом Вот это
яркий пример то что Коля сказал и после
того ты как оставил свой эго за порогом
ты уже пришёл в сообщество А дальше уже
начал развиваться такр У
меня 8 10 лет я работал уже в найме
работал найме Но у меня была сфера такая
тоже гораздо масштабных людей и у меня
сам руководитель был такой более
масштабный он и за счёт этого ну и сфера
сама среда была Где я постоянно
развивался Угу и наверное те функции
которые я выполнял они меня заставляли
развиваться потому что задачи масштаба
плюс Ну сам нетворкинг людей который был
а он был тоже масштабные бизнесмены с
разных стран и общение с ними я это
видел как люди в принципе
Какой бизнес вели общение было то есть с
разных структур но наверное одно было то
что меня заставляло задуматься Это
наверно я ну Работа наверно была не для
души я чувствовал что внутри не было
такого отклика и тогда я задумался что
Ну тогда я как я не был знаком с вами и
вот как Николай сказал Моё первое
соприкосновение с вами Ну с вашей
философией это было видео мастер-класс K
по каен планированию и всё с этого
завертелось тогда и платформа началась я
начал самостоятельно изучать всё
развиваться выделял там каждый день по 3
часа на развитие прошёл самостоятельно
все ну все курсы прошёл И когда я прошёл
миссию там мастер-класс для себя У меня
там с третьего четвёртого Круга всё
время образование обучение Я думал что ж
такое Надо же проверить эту гипотезу и
наверное первое что было Ну для меня
наверное я принял решение попробовать
это и тогда как раз я вот пошёл на
обучение тогда платформу только-только
запустилась А вот ты в сообществе в
каком-то состоял я не состоял в
сообществе Я то есть ты ровно
самостоятельно двигался просто да я ну я
работал в той сфере где было уже
сообщество при нашей при нашей наверное
там при нашей компании можно сказать и
оно было гораздо такое разностное были
люди с разных сфер с разных религий были
с разных стран разные бизнесы я
находился в этой среде и я видел как
люди вообще крутого масштаба растут и
мне было интересно я за счёт этого там
развивался я не проходил Никакое
обучение как бы моя работа это было моё
обучение Это была моя зона роста где то
есть у меня руководитель всегда стоял
задаче высокого уровня говори так Санжар
нужно сделать нужно находить новые пути
решения И за счёт этого я находил
какие-то там дополнительные там книги
читал что-то что-то чтобы решать эти
задачи и в сообществах тоже не состояло
так отдельных и вот первое наверное было
Принятие решения это пойти на обучение
попробовать свою гипотезу и так
сложилось что когда только платформа
запустилась объявили набор там лучших
учеников на трекеры Я понял что нужно
проверить гипотезу ну как бы ну
насколько это действительно у меня
получится Вот я её в течение там года
наверное проверял но находился опять на
своей должности в своей позиции
занимался тем же функционалом но
постепенно постепенно проверяя гипотезу
Я понял что действительно это у меня
хорошо получается и э я как бы внутри
чувствую что вот это вот удовлетворение
есть вот это отклик души моей и я
понимаю что вот появляется что-то
какие-то новые
новые идеи которые раньше может быть Не
появлялись Вот и я постепенно получается
там какими уверенными шагами переходил
вот на ту сторону скажем так но Та
сторона которая была она тоже была для
меня интересна но внутренний отклик души
я не получал я для себя понял что нужно
определить то что действительно будет
тея драйви там не знаю 30 40 50 лет для
меня это было таким ключевым решением я
вот в эту
сторону если вот
подытожить твою историю получается ты
уже находился в крутом сообществе То
есть у тебя компания работала компании в
которой ты работал Ты работал наёмным
менеджером то есть в частной компании
вот здесь у нас госслужба частная по
сути фрилансер
уже и выпускник университета Да и
получается изначально Санжар находился в
хорошей среде где все развивались все
газова и очень крупные были бизнесмены
то есть при этом интересная такая
эволюция получается вроде бы Сиди там и
сиди Да развивайся и развивайся но ещё
одна причина смены а среды и окружения
это тебя дравит или не дравит Вот это
тоже очень важно не надо подходить к
сообществу или КК смене своей среды
только с точки зрения а мне надо вырасти
Ну у него были возможности вырасти но
это не дравит поэтому он ушёл Поэтому
всегда ищите то ту среду которая вас
драйви
если я добавлю что мне ну мне
гарантировали если говорить про спокойно
про стабильность про будущее Мне это всё
гарантировали но я понимал что нужно
наверное прислушаться себя Ну послушать
Себя услышать внутри себя и
действительно Ну хочу ли я это и когда я
понял что я этого не хочу Мне нужно
двигаться дальше Понятно будут что могут
быть падения сложности проблемы Но я
выбрал это этот путь и тогда я начал так
знаете постепенно план б его ровать
пробовать и получать подтверждение
Наверное от людей Ну от компании и вот
Ну вот тоже хорошие показатель
траектория Да у человека всё есть
будущее гарантировано работат частной
компание вокруг очень много крутых
бизнесменов которые развиваются и ты мог
бы спокойно развиваться тоже а при этом
у тебя и будущее как бы гарантировано и
оплата хорошая и при этом у тебя есть
куда расти Есть у кого брать примеры и
так далее ты уже находишься в хорошей
среде но если сердцу Как говорится
Сердцу не прикажешь если это не дравит
то надо менять э среду и окружение то
есть а среду и окружение меняет не
только для того чтобы расти А ещё для
того чтобы находиться в той среде
которая тебе нравится вот это очень
важно Вот если послушать историю
санджара Лика Угу Ну моя история
наверное чем-то похожа с никен и так
скажем мне наверное с окружением везло
вот с самого Рождения потому что наше
самое первое окружение это наши родители
да до 14 лет которые формируют наше
мировоззрение и в том числе наше
мировоззрение на успех А ну родители
научили тому что нет проблем есть задачи
которые Нужно решать всё в итоге можно
решить к чему-то Можно прийти Ну к
такому знаете позитивному
положительному взгляду на жизнь вот
потом был университет Я заканчивала
экономический факультет в МГУ Ломоносова
и там конечно ребята такие
вот
увлечённый которые драйв Да со своими
огромными мечтами амбициями это тоже
меня естественно заряжала я вот просто
сейчас сижу анализирую как окружение
влияло на меня а приехали сюда когда в
Алмату супругом мы начали здесь
открывали бизнес филиалы И это всё вот
этот период занимал где-то около 10 лет
такого активного роста Да когда мы
работали там по 12 14 часов в сутки и в
какой-то момент я всегда была тем
человеком который хочет расти и
развиваться Я всегда искала пути для
этого да и в первую очередь это были
какие-то тренинги где я знакомилась с
новыми людьми и для меня окружение - это
в первую очередь новые идеи идеи и
возможности для роста и развития То есть
это своеобразное так скажем обучение и
мой драйвер роста и вот то о чём говорил
Нур Ахмет когда ты видишь впереди перед
собой человека который имеет эти
результаты они обалденные и это
формирует твоё видение где-то
подсвечивает Твои личные мысли и ты
понимаешь что это не эпизодический
какой-то момент в его жизни а это образ
его жизни Он так живёт и если у него это
есть Why not Почему у тебя не может
получиться так же Да и потом Ну вот это
вот видение картинка потом формируется в
реальность Ну так происходит в твою
реальность и в 2016 году я вступила в
сообщество Woman Inside это сообщество
женского развития которое потом
трансформировалось то что мы открыли
здесь где это находится на Украине они
уже закрылись в оффлайне открыты теперь
только в онлайне Мы в итоге открыли с
подругой здесь центр женского развития
тоже это дало огромный такой толчок и
бост для не только для меня как бы как
для там для предпринимателя но в том
числе для нашего основного бизнеса
потому что мы многие инструменты
стандартизацию автоматизацию внедрили
битрек систему вот благодаря тому что я
видела в том бизнесе Да Во франшизе у и
в какой-то момент в двадцатом году нам
пришлось закрыться потому что из-за
ковида ну там по понятным причинам мы
обучили 2.000 женщин это был классный
кейс и опять такой для меня наступил
определённый вакуум То есть я хотела
дальше расти и развиваться Да а что
дальше и
м начала развивать страничку свою
собственную А про современное искусство
и в двадцать третьем году как раз-таки я
узнаю про кайн клуб в прошлом году и
вступаю и это конечно Просто для меня
было идеальным местом А с точки зрения
того что я получала не только
возможность в виде обучения рост и
развития но в том числе Это был мощный
нетворкинг То есть я видела людей со
схожими ценностями это очень важно Это
люди с которыми вот я могу общаться
спокойно а не думая о том что я сейчас
скажу потому что они разделяют взгляды
они также смотрят на что-то У них такие
же наверное ну похожие проблемы и такие
же оценки же примерная оценка ситуации и
те же самые стремления это очень важно и
это конечно для
меня дало очень много таких важных
моментов в части не только роста
развития но и каких-то
физических результатов которые можно
потрогать То есть например я не знаю Там
мы познакомились с шамилем мута вым это
финансовый консультант он сейчас
помогает управлять личным капиталом
познакомились с тох Жан тоже там у нас
определённый момент там в Дубаях мы
смогли реализовать сейчас с Владом
позняков пытаемся привести Марину
Абрамович Казахстан то есть конкретная
польза пря конкретная польза Да мы к
этому Давайте вернёмся Просто
подытоживая то что Анжелика сказала на
самом деле получается такая вещь у
Анжелики была хорошая среда с детства
плюс она вступила в Украинский клуб Да
женщин Кстати может сложиться
впечатление наверное у наших зрителей в
том что я на самом деле или мы все
агитирует кайзен клуб или сообщество
маргулана инфо нашей платформы и так
далее это абсолютно не так Я хочу
сказать что любое сообщество где люди
объединяются по интересам и где они
развиваются полезно любое вот женское
сообщество пожалуйста а вперёд Я к тому
что не Старайтесь развиваться в одиночку
не имеет значения даже сообщество Мы
сегодня просто берём Как пример Казин
клуб там сообщество нашей платформы и
так далее самая главная мысль которую я
хочу показать вот даже через кейс
Анжелики это не пытайтесь развиваться
самостоятельно потому что наше
настроение оно вот такое и наша
мотивация вот такое и в один день мы
хотим расти в другой день мы
разочаровывается в один день у нас мир
прекрасен в другой день всё ужасно а
именно сообщество которое стабилизирует
и держит нам вот эту траекторию и вы
Вокруг этой траектории вас вот так
колбасит но когда вы в сообществе у вас
всегда есть кому поддержать У вас есть
кому поощрить Иногда вы хотите быть
первым в этом сообществе и так далее и
это очень важная среда Вот например
Анжелики Здесь очень важно две мысли
первая первая мысль что не имеет
значения Какое сообщество Главное чтобы
оно
развивалось мужское женское там
географическое какое-то Московское
Алматинское Киевское не имеет значения
второе об этом мы поговорим ещё чуть
позже то что сообщество даёт конкретный
измеримые конкретную измери пользу для
вашего бизнеса и вообще для вашего
развития Но об этом мы поговорим позже и
так
давайте я и так уже много говорю поэтому
я про себя не буду рассказывать А
давайте перейдём ко второму вопросу
второй вопрос звучит так а что случилось
с вашим старым сообществом в котором вы
были Вы продолжаете общаться или нет
Если продолжаете Почему общаетесь какую
пользу вы получаете от старого
сообщества и Какую Ну Давайте Так я на
ставлю на третий Вопрос какую пользу вы
получаете от Нового сообщества сейчас
хочется поговорить только о вашем старом
сообществе Что случилось с той средой в
которой вы были так Ну тогда я опять
начну очень интересно именно что у тебя
произошло Ну мы по этой схеме мы по этой
схеме двигаемся О'кей поначалу по цель
было Так а как они отнеслись вот что с
ними произошло и как они отнеслись к
твоей эволюции да э
смотрите у меня
несколько было в жизни перемен я работал
на госслужбе Я работал в Министерстве
юстиции я руководил специальной
экономической зоной и вот э вот в квази
госсекторе и вот в каждом есть своё
сообщество госслужащие - это одно
сообщество одни понимания одни принципы
там мы обсуждаем Почему Кого куда
назначили Почему этот министр туда это
меня окие разговоры Да да да это прям
любимая тема Служи самая основная тема
да да да это ни ещё такой свой язык есть
вот это ко
тот вот это потом это он он
универсальный сурдопереводчик Ну в
Турции тоже поймут ты тоже был на
госслужбе Да я иногда бывал в Астане
про Вот это одна история есть квази
госсектор там больше история про
назначение Да кто куда назначил сейчас
команды Все туда перейдём и вот эта
история а
и вы знаете у меня так в жизни
получилось что из каждого места где я
работал у меня по одному-два друга
осталось Вот именно я с ним общаюсь но
не на основе то что мы коллеги и так
далее а то что вот мы друг другу
интересны Но тот круг общения который
был он конечно распался я там уже не
общаюсь и с
ними во-первых со временем не очень а
во-вторых обсуждать Почему министра туда
назначили Я не понимаю меня на мою жизнь
это никак не влияет и соответственно нет
смысла даже это обсуждать А вот когда ты
переходил вот этот момент как они
относились к к этому Ну было два скажем
так два мнения первое Зачем ты это
делаешь Ну типа всё же хорошо Ну смысле
зачем они не понимали то есть ну вот у
тебя карьера идёт то есть понятно что ты
будешь делать а вторая История это была
и том что вернёшься скоро обратно
на колени ползёшь было так вспомнишь мои
слова вспомнишь мои слова Да да да типа
ты же в этом ничего не разбираешься но
ВС жизнь на ного службе провёл и
соответственно вот эта история про
непонимание тебя и так далее но было и
третья история когда я уже начал своим
бизнес заниматься мне люди пришли и
сказали Тебе давно надо было у давно
надо было но они молчали в силу каких-то
причин я не знаю даже я говорю Ну а
почему да да об Ну мы думали тебе и так
всё хорошо м классно вот смотрите здесь
Интересно такую вещь заметили что каждый
раз когда вы меняете свою среду а
обязательно одна группа людей как вот
как старая среда Вас тянет вниз и держит
первое Зачем это тебе надо это первое
второе - это ты всё равно
вернёшься третье - это агрессия это
агрессия очень часто встречается типа ну
что там ну и что там такого то есть
обесценивание и агрессия Почему вообще
возникает агрессия у человека мы люди Мы
агрессивно воспринимаем всё что мы не
понимаем поэтому не надо обижаться с
одной стороны на своё старое окружение
что они хейтят например Да твою новую
деятельность просто они не понимают чем
ты занимаешься И почему госслужащие
часто бизнесменов не любят потому что
они не понимают Как как они деньги
зарабатывают вообще как так получается
Ну а объяснять они могут только в своей
картине мира там это можно либо
своровать либо обмануть либо и так
Дале непонятная история легче Вот свое
картины мира объяснить и так далее И вот
интересно я хотел здесь подчеркнуть что
я когда ушёл с госслужбы и я думал что я
всё знаю я не был в позиции ученика вот
то что ты подчеркнул и я открыл первый
бизнес и я
разорился пря в ноль я е остался должен
я не знал что делать у меня были вот эти
мысли Ну не моё может вернуться может
вернуться они там ждут надо мне обратно
там резюме идти на поклон ребята
погорячился был неправ Дайте мне обратно
тёплое кресло в машину и я вот сейчас
вам опять всё налажу но вот эта история
с хейтерами Да она Иногда помогает тебе
всё-таки не ломаться ты думаешь я сейчас
приду они же на меня вот так будут
смотреть типа ну что неудачник вернулся
типа куда ты денешься мы тебе говорили
это тоже польза есть это польза потому
что я наверное стал продолжать не из-за
того что меня кто-то поддерживал А из-за
того
что да меня такой как я не смогу
опять-таки важность окружения а кругом
то люди могут То есть это не у меня не
какая-то уникально с одной стороны у
тебя было окружение где ты видишь что
другие могут с другой стороны тебе был
страх вернуться в старое окружение где
где уже ждали и говорили Ну что мы тебе
говорим с одной стороны как бы вызов а с
другой стороны пример что могут же да да
и получается получается и там и там
Неда получается два два окружения смотри
два окружения способствовали твоим
успеху одно окружение тем что хейтили и
ожидала что ты провались сав другое
окружение говорило смотри мы все можем
ты тоже да Да всё так и я здесь хотел
важную вещь сказать произнести когда я
вот находился прямо на нулевом балансе у
меня не было энергии вообще я думал всё
пропало я
тогда Вот пытался что-то ещё делать я
полетел в Москву и встретился там с
Мишей и
айдаром ли Казин клуба Кыргызстана Вот и
мы там поговорили почти 5 часов и Айдар
сказал Слушай через месяц слёт в
Стамбуле Прилетай мы с тобой ещё не
договорили Я говорю у меня денег нет Мне
стыдно сказать что меня денег нет я
говорю да я не планирую туда ехать и он
говорит Смотри я тебя буду ждать Угу и
он ушёл с этой мыслью А у меня есть
чувство ответственности вот такой если
человек ждёт я такой надо лететь Ох надо
лететь Я на последние деньги вот сегодня
рассказываю э историю само немножко вону
Я на последние деньги взял билет и
полетел в Стамбул на каленый слёт и у
меня в кармане было на тот момент ровно
200 долларов больше не было вообще денег
я очень круто рад Айдару хочу сказать
спасибо что он это сделал Для меня Я
когда попал на этот слёт Я там никого не
знал там двух-трёх человек но я когда
попал я так был за
за 3 дня я потом мне показалось что то
что денег нет это нормально да потому
что я услышал много кейсов которые
говорят А что нормально Я тоже И вот мы
с ребятами на эту тему общались и у
Айдара сейчас немножко трудное время я
хотел через подкаст поддержать ему
сказать что дай Бог что всё пройдёт у
него благополучно и он вернётся
обратно Айда большая благодарность за то
что вот способствовал видишь твоему
росту
Ну у меня наверное была похожая ситуация
с нурахметов такое
обесценивание когда вот начала работать
Подожди а как объяс у тебя что
студенты студенты да Это классно это
круто но иногда вот когда ты
вот я там закончила
А ну у меня там социальная такая дегри
был Мар дегри и все говорили ну лучше ты
там пойдёшь все это родственники наверно
родственники и может ты там учёный пой
работа или там на госслужбу пойдёшь вот
вообще кто такой марн Калиевич такие
тоже вопросы были да
и но как я уже говорила ранее в принципе
мне повезло в этом плане что Вот ребята
классные ме всегда были И здесь тоже
классное окружение Вот но некоторые из
них всё равно отваливаются с течением
времени А вот и вот я вот заметила что
есть три такие категории роста когда ты
там обсуждаешь людей потом Когда ты
обсуждаешь события И третье Когда ты
обсуждаешь идеи и вот
в нашем сообществе классно когда вот
именно идеи обсуждаются я это каждый раз
замечаю и
м и это прямо такой фактор Бустер для
роста тоже Угу угу поэтому на самом деле
мне очень сложно ответить морлан кович
на ваш вопрос Ну у тебя получается твоё
окружение это так оно было классно да
было классно а потом родственники начали
чуть-чуть это родственники Да ну это ну
родственников мы поменять Да мы поменять
не можем классика жанра родственники
родственники родственники поменяем
Да близкие родственники как правило
понимают и поддерживают эволюцию А вот
дальние всегда тормозят и вот эта вся
история но мы их поменять не можем
вернее
поменять заменить не можем а поменять в
принципе можно где-то но заменить не
можем Ну а не у нас ты договорила Да
договорила у нас Николай Ну вот у меня
наверное из того что я могу рассказать
вообще всё происходило так как выписали
в посте Ну тогда я помню что я не один
такой все вот ахнули тогда что вот так
вот прямо описываете чётко Но я честно
говоря у меня такие отношения с моими
наверное с моими друзьями я не знаю как
они сильно Честно говоря реагировали я
больше был сосредоточен о том как я
реагирую и я понимал что вот есть вот
это Ну как тогда же в самом начале ты
немножко Ты же немножко резкий как бы я
просто так говорю мы же как бы это
трансформация там Су У нас началась ты
немножко резкий ты такой Блин ну как мы
время неэффективно проводим Ну так по
крайней мере в голове где-то что-то
скажешь такое А давайте что-нибудь Вот
ну как бы по-другому и прямо как вы
писали Тогда было вокруг ощущение вот
это что ты какой-то ну ты как Буто не
такой Так ну как бы вчера вот вроде бы
ещё вот там не знаю пиво билярд
обсуждали нормально всё короче говорили
Какие все плохие как бы какие там
сотрудники вообще
никакие Т раз и уже что-то ну типа
хочется спросить а что вот делать да Вот
какие вот инструменты а как вот этой
лучшей версией себя стать Ну вот то есть
вот эта мотивация же появилась И как бы
э обсуждаешь и чувствуешь что это вот ну
не туда Ну это не заходит Да как бы и ты
и потом понимаешь что в принципе э как
бы ну вот те ценности которые в принципе
идут от вас это же Поэтому в принципу
фильтр Да проходил членов клуба что вот
мы мы сидим с 8:00 утра до 11:00
обсуждаем там идеи там ну там обсуждаем
Как лучше Кому что-то сделать уже честно
говоря забываешь что Ты кушал что ты пил
вообще просто такой фон такой вот и ты
понимаешь что оттуда ты выходишь
во-первых с кайфом у тебя энергии дофига
это же тоже важно бывает утром Ну не
знаю Мне 45 наверное Может из-за этого
но важно Вот перед рабочим днём что вот
у тебя энергии вообще валом у тебя
столько кейсов столько всяких мыслей Ты
быстренько идёшь начинаешь их записывать
внедрять потом смотришь там вот у нас
там ну там же переходишь третий вопрос
Что даёт нам новое окружение А ты проста
Ну вот Ну вот и составом получается что
я делаю сейчас составом уже как бы я уже
этот этап резки прошёл Вот теперь я
пытаюсь относиться немножко Вот
рационально Я например прихожу на Ну
какие-то сборища и просто вот это
опять-таки позиции ученика и позиции
наблюдателя я я думаю ну что-то
эффективно мы можем точно отсюда
вытащить позитивные эмоции вспоминать
прошлое В принципе неплохо один раз там
в месяц например вот что-то вот как
сказать ну эти же люди близкие мне я всё
равно то есть Пытаюсь всё равно как бы
как сказать поддерживать какие-то связи
но понимаю что ну занижают ожидания от
этого да А вот смотри это да получается
произошла эволюция твоего восприятия
Сначала ты как юношеский максимализм их
как бы ну поставил на них крест Да а
потом сейчас уже более рационально начал
к этому подходить и пытаться максимум
выжимать не то что выжимать А понимать
что они то я коси визирова просто этого
не так много вот это более эффективно
вот как они отнеслись к тому что чем ты
начал заниматься Ну ну они по-разному
они понятно что я такой как бы жертва
инфобизнеса наверное вот такой примерно
ну я честно говоря может быть у меня
такие отношения с друзьями они не так
резко проявляют свои как-то ко мне вот
так вот
Ну я думаю они просто не сильно заметили
эволюцию Ну был кинопродюсер сейчас
какой-то YouTube Ну тоже про картинки
про видео Ну они нет но они всё равно
понимают вот в социальных сетях же
меняется же всё равно ты как выставляешь
какие-то картинки Ты понимаешь что там
одно время там я не знаю там в пятницу
вечер там дискач А теперь там не знаю
Кан слёт там с утра с 8 что во вобще на
работу надо к 10к о приходить то есть
Поэтому соответственно Конечно есть
что ты чем-то вот это развитие такое да
заточил На это развитие вообще даёт тебе
что-то не даёт осторожненько так
спрашивают там типа вообще есть смысл
там вот например
Наста я пошёл люди не понимают что они
думают ну хорошо другие бизнесмены пошли
вот как бы сделки находят продажи делают
Ну у тебя там ни одного там ну ты не
можешь никакой продажи делать Да ну то
есть нет ни одного человека кто может
быть твоим Как сказать
парт зачем туда ходишь ещё деньги
заплатил за это зачем вообще время
проводишь вообще непонятно на что есть
такое непонимание но видите Ну время
меняется поэтому я гово на такой стадии
уже очень принятия и спокойного
отношения к этому просто рационально ты
дозируется тоже получается случайно
увидел моё видео в общем моё видео
действует отравляющее Я так понимаю
увидел моё видео и решил развиваться и
а купил один из наших продуктов нашей
платформы не буду говорить какой чтобы
не вычислили его но смысл такое он
первые месяцев восемь был хейтером он
купил продукт при этом он хейтер и очень
да находился и очень скептически ко
всему так относился типа ну блин ну типа
вот так угу а потом я с ним разговаривал
говорю а что что случилось Почему так
это ну периодически спрашиваю
Оказывается это потом уже когда он этот
а потом интересно Там он взял годовую
программу 8 месяцев 9 месяцев он вот так
похер относился как-то этот критически
всё Оценил а потом что-то у него
перемкнуть
развиваться потом я у него спрашиваю Что
произошло он говорит Ну я говорит знал
что понял для себя что надо развиваться
и говорит пришёл но моё окружение
постоянно говорит мне просто мозг
выносили типа ну и что ты там нашёл и
что Толку И что это тебе эффект дало Ну
что ты заработал на этом Ну иче где
деньги Покажи результат и меня говорит
вот так меня окружение моё говорит
постоянно Ну мы же ходим в баню в
бильярд там ещё караоки и так далее а он
госслужащий в этих органах и все типа ну
и что ты там ну говорит вашим именем
обзывали меня типа ты уже стал его там
фанатам после это он типа секту
открыл А я гово А я Говори С каждым днём
вижу что мне неинтересно с ним просто с
ними я начал потихоньку потихоньку
отдаляться и в какой-то момент говорит
уже отдалился получается от того берега
ушёл а к этому берегу не пристал и у
меня говорит такой ту сразу произошло
такое резкое изменение что типа я должен
определиться но туда точно уже не хотел
идти потому что Чере месяцев Для меня
это как знаете вот как смрад то есть
старьё знаете запах старья я прям точно
я се говори понял что я той жизнью
больше жить не хочу и раз сразу
переключился го вот интересно тоже вот
такое
бывает так Ну у меня так как я
изначально выбрал стратегию нужно
постепенно проверять
гипотезу
вот я Ну я как год год находился
постепенно
второе окружение явно тебя не хейло нет
ме Потому что ты у тебя хорошая было
окружение да Самое интересное что это
первое когда я проверял гипотезу год я
её проверил и когда случилось
определённое там ну как бы события когда
я уже принял решение перейти в
сообщество самое Интересно что ну как бы
моё прежнее там сообщество оно меня
поддержало то есть у меня было три
варианта первое мне сказали давай и там
и тут но я понял что не будет
концентрации фокуса второе Говорит что
супер Давай классно пробуй и третий
вариан Если не получится Мы ждём тебя
брат вот супер благожелательно да да мне
было Прямо супер комфортно вообще на той
стороне вообще уних всё хорошо вообще не
Вот кстати кстати А смотрите вот разница
когда Санжар находился в сообществе где
тоже люди развиваются и люди крутые
заметьте Он уходил от того сообщества и
они вместо того чтобы хейтить дали три
варианта да давайте Давай параллельно И
даже если у тебя не получится мы тебя
обратно ждём Вот это ещё раз
подчёркивают насколько важно сообщество
то сообщество которое развивается и если
даже вы его покидаете Оно всегда будет
вас ждать Ну с удовольствием и если
отвечать на вопрос что связь у меня с
этим сообществом есть я Ну может быть не
такая сейчас активно Как как в прошлом
но связь я держу потому что я понимаю
что это один из Может быть одна из
возможностей нетворкинга решение
каких-то может быть проблем но в
принципе и Они открыты и я открыт То
есть у нас такая атмосфера
доброжелательно сложилась Я понимаю что
всё-таки за годы работы там 8-10 лет я
строил Ну для меня важно было построить
крепкие отношения я принял для себя
решение что нужно их сохранять так или
иначе Вот видишь такие отношения стоит
сохранять Это крутой пример абсолютно
обратный так Анжелика Ну у меня как-то в
жизни складывалось всегда Всё органично
то есть вот старое наверное окружение
которое мне просто Лось неинтересно с
этими людьми и это выливалась в то что
когда мы общались Ну возникали какие-то
паузы в разговоре нам не о чем было
говорить И постепенно просто Мои встречи
с такими людьми сокращались всё ну
становилось их всё меньше и меньше
потому что для меня самое главное когда
я общаюсь с другим человеком это
энергообмен то есть вот когда я ухожу
После разговора Как говорит Николай
заряженная то есть вот полно каких-то
мыслей идей Я прямо чувствую эту энергию
то это мой
для себя вот так вот определяю а в целом
так скажем я Ну наверное не делю людей
для себя в своей голове вот я такая
развитая они там неразвитые я уже ушла
на такую-то ступень нет у нас просто
поменялись интересы Нам просто не о чем
разговаривать они не тили там или у меня
знаете как у меня наоборот получилось
наоборот меня как будто бы стали больше
уважать больше уважать И где-то это
знаете мешает потому что
со мной могли Ну часть моих друзей могли
более откровенно разговаривать а сейчас
они не могут наверное или не хотят или
думают о том что мне сказать И конечно
здесь есть вот такой
вот смотрите второе подтверждение того
что вот Анжелика была до прихода к нам в
хорошем в хорошей среде и вот когда ты
выходишь из хорошей среды в другую
хорошую среду там х Не бывает Да
интересно вот да долгосрочная це
разошлись мне не стало интересно но
хейта нет Вот это тоже как подтверждение
Давайте переходим к третьему нашему
вопросу А что новое сообщество или новая
среда вам дала Вот что вам дала причём
мы говорим от ощущений до
конкретики прямо конкрет и ещё очень
важно Давайте в этом же третьем вопросе
чтобы не вводить его в четвёртый вопрос
Давайте обсудим
сразу как использовать Ну в кавычках
использовать
новую среду Когда вы приходите в Новую
среду Как эффективно использовать
выжимать из неё
максимум Ну чтобы всё время не было про
клуб Да расскажу ещё одну историю про
силу
сообщества я много лет прожил в октау с
семьёй был руководителем специальной
экономической зоны Почти год и через год
когда поменялась ам области я
соответственно тоже был вын покинуть это
для недели Сидел дома я не знал мне
делать да потому что госслужба вроде
кончилась и вроде в Астану надо
возвращаться или что я тут не очень
понимал потому что город был незнаком
Тогда для меня и в это время ко мне
начали приходить предложения по работе Я
думаю А почему вы начинаю Почему нет Я
оказывается в силу того что я самый
старший в семье у меня вот это есть
стремление к собиранию людей всё время я
их там своих братьев лаши там 40 плюс
двоюродных братьев и сестёр я постоянно
как бы с ними
коммуницируют когда был на специальной
коно зоны я постоянно инвесторов собирал
и пытался их соединить что ну условно у
того есть свет У тебя есть газ Поделись
давайте быстрее вот так вот так вот так
и благодаря тому что я вот так себя
проявлял в этом сообществе эти же
инвесторы начали мне предлагать работу у
да Это история про проявленной то что
всё-таки мы когда говорим попадаешь в
сообщество но не надо ждать что
сообщество тебе что-то даст Классно Вот
это классная идея Ты должен наоборот
туда что-то вложить тогда увидев какой
ты человек Как ты себя ведёшь Какие
поступки тогда и к тебе будет отношение
же такое же давай я тебе что-то тоже
готов с тобой поделиться Угу и для меня
это было очень крутое э для меня как бы
ответ что да всё что я делаю Это не
просто так я тогда понял что А нормально
У меня есть предложение Я теперь уже не
то что сижу и думаю что мне делать У
меня есть возможность выбора Куда мне
пойти в каком направлении классно
вот если делать вывод из этой истории
получается вот когда я говорю давайте
поговорим о том как максимум выжимать из
сообщества или нового сообщества новой
среды в которую вы попадаете первое что
нужно делать нужно проявляться и быть
полезным другим Потому что есть много
людей которые попадают но сообщество и
ходят молчуна Угу Да я заметил вообще и
в Казин клубе такое бывало что молчуны
они как-то вот так потихоньку на
периферии где-то ходят Никакой пользы
для себя в принципе не извлекают и
вторая История это уже ка зн клубом
связанная
Э ты так себя настраиваешь это
опять-таки сообщество когда Ну такая
Атмосфера когда всё помогает друг другу
и ты уже сидишь и смотришь какие-то вещи
чтобы было бы Полезно не только тебе А
ещё кому-то у
и вот это проявление себя есть мы
говорим Зачем что даётся Ты должен
говорить Ребят я вот это могу я вот этим
Могу поделиться и вот эта постоянная
коммуникация отдача отдача отдача тогда
она работает лучше всего и если мы
говорим уже про конкретные примеры там в
астанинское кайн клубе у нас один из
членов клуба собирается строить там
большой родо комплекс и мы там уже
квартиры разобрали ничего себе да же
гово Это моя это моя там и уже там он
говорит я уже пол комплекса продал У вас
теперь локальной ещё будет Всё собст
буде Ну да мы уже очень тесно мы уже
хотим быть рядом настолько что мы
говорим Давай ты будешь моим соседом Я
хочу чтобы ты был моим соседом потому
что я вижу Конкретно что я это же
история про то что не выбирай дом
Выбирай соседа дадада да Вот кстати тоже
не выбирай дом Выбирай соседа классное
прямо высказывание и ещё вот свойства
развивающего
в том что в НМ Каждый хочет поделиться
полезностью с другим Да вот класс Ну для
меня коммьюнити - это во-первых
профессию во-вторых это то как я вижу
этот мир Угу То есть я думаю что
действительно содействие это лучше чем
противодействие и здесь вот я согласна с
нурахметов А что А что коммьюнити
сообщество - это не про зрителей которые
сидят это про сотворчество то есть когда
мы когда мы вместе когда мы вместе
нормальный Казахстан например да вместе
У нас есть какая-то идея цель и мы Вот
её достигаем вместе потому что ну
окружение как же говорит окружение
сильнее воли Вот и действительно в этом
плане сообщество очень сильно помогает
тебе не слиться не сдаться и вот одну
какую-то общую идею мы все вместе И мы
все как бы заодно
вот и мне честно говоря не очень
нравится ф выжимать Максиму сообщество
зна на одном спектре ники сидят зрители
у а на другом романтики я специально
задал вопрос так чтобы даже ников это
заделать типа о а можно что-то выжимать
из
сообщество а внутри уже Отвечая на
вопрос мы говорим ребята выжимать прежде
чем выжимать нужно самому вымогает
на ваш вопрос для меня как для
коммьюнити менеджера очень Прямо большая
награда видеть как раскрываются
потенциал резидентов это прямо вот ты
видишь ты знакомишься с ним одним А
через какое-то время он вообще другой и
ты понимаешь что ты приложила к этому
руку и это просто честно говоря магия
происходит
и вот Ну коммьюнити да менеджер если
вот то есть мы помогаем раскрывать
потенциал
и благодаря сообществу мы сами
раскрываем
потенци это помогать другим раскрывать
потенциал вот это вот я тоже поняла Вот
но да сообщество это это больше про
сотворчество это больше не про то что я
хочу выжить максимум эти таких людей
сразу видно что вот а можно контакты
поделиться А когда ты действительно
искренний когда ты действительно хочешь
помочь отдать тогда да И вот в ка клубе
наме мне такие ситуации когда ребята
парт наме НАТО от сне месте Даурен и
фатхулла с РМ там там в Астане есть
Дулат и гани которые тоже
скооперироваться
такие кейсы это прямо вот награда Угу
Таким
образом получается хорошее сообщество
или новое сообщество даёт Первое это
сотворчество То есть это тот случай
наверное когда ты можешь мыслить о
других да то есть ты берёшь свою идею и
обувает её об других и собираешь
обратную связь от всех и Либо твоя идея
Валиди ется То есть ты понимаешь что она
стоящая либо понимаешь что надо её
как-то подкорректировать То есть
получается Первое - это
творчество развивает сообщество второе -
это помогает принимать решения то есть
это по сути такой постоянно действующий
каф или исследование рынка по сути вы
всё время исследуете рынок и сообщество
помогает принимать решения и третья
хорошая мысль - это то что сообщество
сильнее Воли Да действительно именно вот
эта среда она сильнее воли Ты когда
хочешь слиться среда тебе не позволяет
слиться классно Так Коля Да я хотел вот
рассказать это действительно был Инсайт
прошлого года для меня вот мы как раз с
никен как раз поговорили и я понял что
ну мы всегда же говорили про сообщество
вы тогда выступали я ну как воспринимал
вот ну там сообщество вот новый тренд
это сообщество Да там я такой ну
сообщество это вот то что мы вот даже
есть там клуб там и так далее но потом я
понял что это Ну даже если
абстрагироваться от абстрактного это
очень конкретный инструмент Он такой ну
такой не про общество А вот очень
конкретны потому что вот у меня была
такая
ситуация как бы вот ну там один одна
бизнес леди в общем она спрашивала была
консультация по юбу А это было для неё
новае Вот и мы разговариваем Она говорит
Слушайте а вот где можно взять
сообщество которое вот бизнес в юбе я
такой нет такого
сообщества м говорит А я всегда вот
когда новую тему изучаю вхожу новую тему
я стараюсь сразу попасть в сообщество и
для меня так как бы понимаете для меня
вот от этого таких абстрактных каких-то
вещей вот это вот Кан клуб 300 человек
вот оно вот судилось вот вот же
конкретный инструмент Я говорю Ну
давайте мы создадим такое сообщество
если вам будет легче то есть вот И
теперь я тоже стал решил так действовать
что это инструмент Вот который можно по
разному там Понятно должен быть вин-вин
всегда да то есть ну не будет другой
человек просто там делать Да Это должно
быть интересно людям я вот теперь тоже
так какая-то новая тема Или что-то надо
обсудить надо вот релевантных людей
которым тоже это интересно ну просто вот
собрать вот сейчас там например
мастермайнд какой-нибудь вот на тему Как
бы если им интересно Ну скорее всего
если им интересно не будет ничего делать
раз там с ними пообсуждали новые как бы
темы как бы ну в смысле вот как вы
говорите Друг об друга обсудили или же
вот у нас вот опять-таки внутри нашего
сообщества уже которого там почти 4 года
буквально на прошлой неделе просто
кластери зру и говорим там например вот
недавно поехали поездку вот без цели так
скажем на 3 дня очем важно
сформулировать цель тогда мы сразу
сформулировали мы едем на машине потому
что это возможность в замкнутом
пространстве обсуждать как бы развива ну
вот развиваться как бы вот и классно
время проводить и ничто нам не будет
мешать потому что мы куда-то едем и
когда мы там Поехали у нас там
Приключения были мы там границу
переходили но там не было цели условно
говоря добраться до Чимкента до Ташкента
была цель классно провести Вот это время
и каждый раз когда у нас были
неприятности какие-то мы говорили Ну это
же ну мы-то вместе должны это прожить и
Кроме этого дополнительным конечно
бонусом большого сообщества что мы там в
мхн приезжаем там Мы специально не
говорили им за день потому что они бы
там такой бы устроили Мы за 2 часа такие
в Таразе где-то мы прие они уже там все
собрались время достаточно чтобы
приготовили плов Да хоя хотя просто пло
а то там знаете не выпустят из города
это тоже приятно же приезжаешь в город
там уже такие уже все
я я тоже нашим ребятам тоже говорю Надо
просто признать что мы не просто
одноклубников единомышленники это очень
важно но самый главный Инсайт вот что
это прямо конкретный инструмент что вот
Ну так не просто буть в сообществе А вот
у тебя какая-то задача У тебя есть один
из инструментов сообщество и ты раз его
применяет
решение конкретных проблем да да да вот
это возьмём от Коли и второе вот друзья
единомышленники А я сейчас начал даже в
последнее время говорить что появился
новый тип родственников Угу Да но это
новый тип родственников Когда ты уже это
не просто друзья Я считаю вот друзья
единомышленники - Это круто когда у
вас одинаково вы мыслите и развивайтесь
оба но Кай клуб - это даже смотрите
разница в чём когда у тебя друзья
единомышленники вы общаетесь плотно с
ним до тех пор пока какая-то сторона
развивается стоит одной стороне
перестать развиваться ты уходишь вперёд
и постепенно перестаёшь общаться с этим
человеком Либо наоборот он уходит вперёд
и так далее но в сообществе как правило
если кто-то начинает отставать ты
начинаешь его подтягивать и таким
образом связь не прерывается если ты
начинаешь что-то хандрить он тебя что
случилось Давай и так далее поэтому я
это назвал новый тип родственника да да
Круто
Так ну у
меня всё начиналось ведь с создания
команды как раз сформировалась команда
тогда не было ещё ни клуба и всё
остальное и Ну я для себя такое как бы
наверное так
по интуитивно сформировалось правило что
в первую очередь Да вот то что вы
сказали Нура Ахмед это проявляться это
быть полезным в первую очередь заявить о
себе как ты можешь быть полезным и тогда
люди ну как бы открыты к тебе в первую
очередь то есть это наладить такой
Контакт как даже знаете угу вот второе
Наверное я когда вот мы вот внутри
команды всё это строилось наверное
заявить о о чётких целях что я хочу куда
я иду Ну как бы я это и сделал потому
что мне кажется Когда ты заявляет
очередь ты не сливаешь во-вторых
сообщество знает команда сообщество
знает о своих целях И
третье использовать сообщество команду
как инструмент который Может тебе помочь
вырасти
То есть это могут быть разные форматы
мастермайнд брейншторм ещё что-то и
тогда то есть когда Ну как я для себя
понял что Заявляю о целях видят Куда ты
идёшь и тебе как бы создаётся такая
большая поддержка людей Угу и четвёртое
Наверное это така умение получать
обратную связь где-то там адекватный
неадекватный и принимать эту обратную
связь Вот наверное благодаря этому если
го Конкретно что прошло то есть Я
перешёл там к вам в Ну я начинал с этапа
волонтёрства очень важно
и сегодняшняя моя точка
Филька я получается что полноценно Ну
как бы в найме занимаюсь Это мой
основной вид деятельности и Ну я считаю
что благодаря вот таким принципам Я
наверное пришёл к текущей точке Круто
очень круто Здесь получается дополнение
к Лайф Нура ахмета о том как максимум
выжимать из сообщества когда Смотрите е
раз подчеркну когда мы говорим Маси
общест мы автоматически начинаем думать
что мы выжимаем но на самом деле Чтобы
максимум выживать из сообщества Ты
должен тоже этому сообществу отдать так
вот Нура Ахмет сказал что надо
проявляться это очень круто проявляться
и
всем помогать но Санжар хорошее
Дополнение - это декларировать о своих
целях Когда вы приходите в сообщество вы
декларирует свои цели это помогает не
слиться Вам самим люди знают ваши цели и
знают как вам помочь и дальше уже
проявляться то есть с одной стороны вы
приходите помогаете другим людям
достигать своих целей а с другой стороны
декларируется им своих целей Потому что
если вы А вот члены сообщества или вашей
среды не декларируют свои целей то
периодически вы даже не знаете как ему
помочь и это Это крутой лайфхак на самом
деле и ещё что мне особенно понравилось
это а среда - это место где ты можешь
получать обратную связь и она такая не
травмирующие а поддерживающая обратная
связь Это круто Анжелика у меня
получается опыт был в трёх сообществах
Вот первое украинска про которой я вам
рассказала Ну про результаты вы уже
знаете потом А это кайн клуб И сейчас я
ещё в одном состою тоже женском
сообществе Я хочу поговорить про кайдзен
потому что результатов действительно
много для меня я не ожидала что будет
так много результатов честно признаюсь а
и когда на встрече первый раз никен
помнит Мы собирали потенциальных членов
клуба Угу Это был ужин и как раз
выступал по-моему Кайрат из Астаны и в
тот вечер когда я прослушала всё о чём
говорят резиденты я подумала Да я хочу с
этими людьми общаться коммуницировать и
быть быть в этом сообществе после этого
Вот я приняла это решение Но даже тогда
я не знала каких когда они рассказывали
о этих колоссальных результатах успехах
успехах Я всё равно немножко скептически
к этому относилась а потом поняла что Да
вот сейчас я оцениваю смотрю назад
Спустя год первое - это конечно обучение
я прошла курс ТСЖ прошла курс по каден
планированию по трела И это не просто
прошла Я нашла людей с которыми в
дальнейшем потом общаюсь и так далее но
я применяю эти инструменты в жизни
смогла сформулировать свою миссию и это
так здорово действительно под миссию
теперь пространство начинает
поворачиваться столько приходят
возможности даже вот то что мы сейчас
сидим здесь с вами это тоже часть той
миссии которую я сформулировала для себ
потому что одна из её там частей звучит
так Я делюсь знаниями и опытом с миром
накопленными второе а это конечно
различные такие небольшие кейсы Но это
всё как бы вот вот работает это так вот
там я нашла в нашем кайн сообществе
нашла Шамиля мутала это финансового
консультанта который помогает нам теперь
там инвестировать грамотно Личные
финансы не знаю С Владом
хотим и планируем привезти Марину
Абрамович в Казахстан надеемся что
получится а получилось Там из тогжан
поработать из Зарины то есть везде
кто-то из резидентов стал нашим
поставщиком по логистике в компании то
есть вот вчера встречалась тоже с
Русланом ну постоянно есть какие-то вы
знаете нельзя сказать что это что-то вот
конкретно одно но кейсов наверное 20 -
это которые такие небольшие результаты
Но которые сильно повлияли И самое
главное я смогла тоже вот мастер-класс
провести для ребят там тоже рассказывала
для кайзен клуба и тоже для меня это
возможность опять-таки свою миссию
реализовать в общем очень конечно
хорошие положительные для меня
результаты А если вот говорить по поводу
того А как выжить Да максимум из
сообщества А я скажу про то что нужно
проявлять инициативу и самое главное
здесь не просто проявлять они боятся её
проявлять очень часто мы же когда
приходим в новое сообщество люди там уже
не год не два они знают друг друга там
некоторые по нескольку лет и мы боимся
Ну вот я сейчас к нему подойду и скажу А
он тут уже вот а что он обо мне подумает
вот надо просто идти и говорить Привет
Меня зовут Анжелика я там компания
электроком не все должны Анжелика
говорить Да не все некоторые должны
говорить Николай Николай хотя хотя
неплохой способ познакомиться да ты
приходишь такой бородатый мужик и
говоришь Привет Меня зовут Анжелика меня
запомнят точно Почему не боя Потому что
если ты в своём сообществе тебя всегда
поддержат Ну то есть всегда будут идти
тебе навстречу и не будет вот этого
какого-то там неодобрения неправильного
оценочного суждения Угу круто получается
сообщество помимо всего прочего ещё
а вплетено просто в
каждодневные Операции каждодневные
действия и ты с большим удовольствием
воспользуешься услугами члена сообщества
Потому что есть Доверие чем какого-то
специалиста на стороне и при этом
коллективный опыт и коллективные знания
сообщества гораздо больше чем у тебя
точно Ну Это всегда так да люди же всё
равно как-то вокруг ценност же
объединяются тоже получается люди
объединяются вокруг ценности а потом
между собой оказывают себе друг другу
кучу пользы я ещё один хотел момент
Отметь моч по поводу
сообщества про важность обратной связи и
вот я хотел про честную обратную связь
потому что человек редко когда получает
честную обратную связь особенно если он
достиг каких-то высот какого-то ему
обычно Ну стесняются или не хотят с ним
портить отношения и как-то замаливать
какие-то и мы в Остане клубе решили
как-то собрались и говорит Давайте
ребята честно друг другу давать обратно
Вот давайте один раз договоримся что не
обижаемся даже если мне слова твои
неприятны но не будем обижаться потому
что мы хотим чтобы мы росли то знаете
когда мы это сделали и ты уже не боишься
сказать Вот тут ты не прав либо тут ты
не то не сделал И это поначалу вызывало
токое отторжение как бы как я не прав Я
всегда прав у нас есть ребят но когда мы
это перешли в черту мы уже перешли к
следующей о том что я об этом подумаю
Угу то что ты мне сказал я об этом
подумал не отрицание а окей ты в это
видишь во мне да тогда Я хорошо ребята
тогда я останавливаемся Давайте и мы
получили такой эффект что ты получаешь
место где тебе честно круто что-то
говорят и не боятся тебя
прямо а вот это тво эго уже уже открыто
пр это на самом деле очень круто Я в
самом начале Кан клуба даже тоже говорил
говорю смотрите Вы Возьмите себе за
правило такое если тебе кто-то говорит
что-то неприятное и ты обижаешься то ты
не с нами Просто скажи причём Я
предлагал даже
написать Напиши что если тебе говорят и
ты обижаешься то я не это сообщество не
для меня Я клянусь клянусь уйти из него
и вот это вот эта Клятва у человека
держит С одной стороны сообщество
слишком привлекательно а с другой
стороны его есть Клятва и у него
Остаётся вариант только принять обратную
связь какая бы она неприятна ни была и
вы знаете насколько это важно любая
обратная связь Она резко увеличивает
нашу эффективность потому что вот
смотрите есть реальность и есть картинка
наша картинка об этой реальности вот
когда реальность и картинка совпадают Мы
попадаем в кризис а что такое реальность
реальность - это события которые
происходит а картинка - это наше
ожидание на самом деле И вот если вы там
ночью голодный холодный уставший после
работы приходит домой и думает сейчас
жена бросится на шею и скажет ой Дорогой
мы тебя ждём и так далее открываешь
дверь а она говорит Где ты шляешься твоя
работа из-за этой работы ты уже семью
забыл Происходит что происходит твоё
ожидание не соответствует факту и
происходит кризис в ваших отношениях
поэтому ребята смотрите кризис - это
всегда Когда ваша картинка мира Или ваши
ожидания не соответствует реальности и
вот обратная связь нужна для того чтобы
всё время приводить в соответствие
Потому что если вы не будете получать
обратную связь особенно негативную то у
вас картинка съедет и вы всё время
будете натыкаться на то что оказывается
реальность другая и соответственно не
можете применять эффективные инструменты
напоследок я хочу обсудить короткую бриф
Угу
А как определить здоровые отношения или
нет Вот давайте так по одному накида вот
развивающие отношения какие отношения
являются развивающим мы сегодня уже
вокруг говорили каждый просто по одному
У меня два таких бриф вопроса
коротких Кто
готов отношения для меня это которые в
первую очередь расширяют мой Горизонт и
дают
виде Круто
Так я хочу добавить тоже это такая фраза
акас Я это могу и ака это умею Спасибо
что научили Спасибо что показали То есть
если ты приходишь к такому мнению то
отношения Значит так я на сказал если
это просто на уровне чувства если в этих
отношениях ты чувствуешь прилив энергии
тогда это
отлично Круто Да круто я прямо хотел
сказать про обесценивание Ну что вот
если если этот элемент но в принципе
более точнее Конечно рахта Потому что
действительно Ну всё равно скажи что да
но я про то что вот
это как сказать очень часто
распространённое это вот оценка чему-то
обсуждать кого-то или что-то и
обесценивать вот это это ну как просто
элемент Ну не сильно здоровых
отношений наверное тако как я чувствую
это ресурсное состояние когда у тебя
появляется ресурс появляется мотивация и
ты пря чувствуешь что у тебя такой рост
наверное Вот Угу угу возможно так Ну я
бы наверное добавил ещё что
а всегда развивающие отношения Они как
правило глубокие угу вот просто глубокие
Потому что если у вас общение
поверхностное то ничего ни к чему это не
приведёт потому что смотрите в основе
всего лежит Доверие если нету доверия
нету глубоких отношений а нету глубоких
отношений нету развития То есть ты
обратную связь не получишь нормальную а
ты и энергию не получишь потому что
поверхностные отношения никогда не дают
энергию и ты не увидишь перспективы
потому что с тобой никто не будет
делиться поэтому глубина отношений она
прямо показывает на уровень доверия
между вами Давайте ещё один блиц вопрос
задам А по каким Метрика определять что
вы растёте Угу Ну это
такой Ну вот практический лайфхак
который я вот да Как определить что ты
растёшь Ну я думаю что это всё-таки
такая
история если что-то напоминает вам
например Ну вот например в Фейсбуке есть
вот эта история Воспоминания да или там
ты встречаешь какого-то человека который
год назад встретил и ты хотя бы
чуть-чуть порассуждаем ты вспомнишь как
ты размышлял год назад как Ты рассуждал
год назад Ну я думаю что как бы если ты
растёшь то ты думаешь Ну такой ты такой
тупой был короче вот я у меня так ты
настолько был тогда тупой ты вообще
думал вот так вот так вообще оказалось
всё не так вообще но и И сейчас ты как
бы про будущее что-то думаешь и через
год Опять ты такой если задумаешься ты
подумаешь Блин ну ты вообще ошибался
вообще всё не так опять Ну мне кажется
что это такой элемен да Классно Классно
Это Метрика это когда ты смотришь назад
и прошлые твои решения мысли проблемы
кажутся мелкими И вообще видение оно
другое Вообще видение подругому другою
так я Ага да нуно У мене как-то три
таких пункта вырисовывается это первое -
это твой уровень или масштаб твоего
мышления второе наверное Уровень твоего
дохода как ты сильно растёшь и третий
наверное твоё окружение
Ага а вот твоё окружение как вот
определить Ну наверное А если ты растёшь
у тебя всё время растёт окружение
масштаб людей которые тебя окружают Угу
и благодаря этому масштабу Вот масштаб
людей Да классно так в этом я у меня
есть классный лайфхак это надо спросить
у своей супруги или су это люди которые
лучше вас знают и я так делаю и моя
супруга она благодарна что я вообще в
кан клуб попал вообще ты стал другим
человеком классная Метрика метри простая
спросить у своего близкого человека год
назад Каким я был и год назад и как ты
чувствуешь что что произошло супер супер
возможно какие-то новые инструменты
которые ты внедрил которые ты применяет
я согласна со всеми какие-то новые
инструменты что-то что ты взял для себя
и ты такой Ну да я это взял применяю Я
вырос Ари
е вспомнил про супругу сказали меня
месяца два назад супругу задавал вопрос
Ну как раз в начале года когда мы там
планировали я писал там версию 2.0 и так
далее говорит гово а Какая следующая
точка твоя го что ты говорит с места не
[смех]
двигаешься У меня супр тоже она говорит
я обучение не прохожу но я вижу что
хорошего для
меня которые были сложными
недосягаемые когда-то они становятся
простыми понятными и становятся частью
какой-то знаете неосознанной
компетентности когда я могу это уже
делать теперь легко и просто это вот
когда ты начинаешь кататься на лыжах и
ты смотришь на чёрную трассу на вершину
ты думаешь Нет не не Нет это вообще
невозможно а потом в какой-то момент ты
берёшь и спускаешься по этой чёрной
трассе не просто со страхом А с радостью
с драйвом с адреналином тебе это
нравится и ты смотришь назад и думаешь а
когда-то же это было для меня вообще
невозможно
Да ну то есть тоже в сравнени
ретроспективно Да ну нам пора уже
ва у меня У меня
есть один показатель Я вообще в любых
сложных ситуациях всегда предпочитаю
вычислить самый главный основной
показатель главный критерий по котором я
ориентируюсь для меня этот показатель
очень простой моё отношение к
дискомфорту Я заметил такую веь Чем
больше я расту тем проще отношусь к
дискомфорту
то есть что такое дискомфорт значит я
тем меньше Я боюсь потому что страх
будущего страх чего-то не добиться страх
чего-то сделать это вызывает дискомфорт
получение негативной обратной связи
вызывает
дискомфорт знакомиться с новыми людьми
дискомфорт вот эти все новый проект
начинать дискомфорт Ну то есть страх по
сути и моё отношение Я заметил так по ме
Чем больше я расту тем проще отношусь ко
всем я Смело иду не не боясь то есть я
могу уйти в негативную связь слушать
спокойно негативную обратную связь я я
при этом спокойно понимать это критика
или э просто хейт и так далее я могу
спокойно начинать новый проект я не
боюсь там а потерять э репутацию Ну
условно говоря не то что репутацию не
потеряешь я не боюсь что там кто-то
начнёт резко меня хейтить и так далее я
не боюсь потерять имущество я не боюсь
потерять Славу я не боюсь то есть каждым
разом тем больше ты двигаешься наверх
тем больше страхов ты выкидываешь
и вот ловите себя только на одном факте
оба дискомфорт раз какой-то дискомфорт
раз кто-то тебя критикал и ты сразу
думаешь Блин мне больно да но Год назад
я вообще взорвался бы бошку сломал бы а
сейчас тебе просто больно а ты дойдёшь
до уровня когда тебе не просто больно а
ты даже поблагодари этого человека а это
уже
личность должна вырастить при котором
смотрите даже в религии уже Говори
говорится если ударили по левой шке
поставь правую но в исламе говорится ещё
круче в плане того что там говорится так
если тебе сделали зло ответь тем что
лучше А что может быть лучше зла Первое
- это не делать в ответку зло а второе -
это сделать добро то есть тебе человек
сделал зло А ты ему Добро это высший
пилотаж развития человека когда зло
можешь ответить добром но я пытаюсь
научиться хотя бы на зло не отвечать
злом Ну то есть вот и каждый раз я
понимаю что Что такое что вызывает
дискомфорт дискомфорт каждый раз
вызывает во-первых страх А во-вторых
когда ты идёшь к своей цели что-то Тебе
мешает да и ты такой блин эти проблемы
запарили и так далее и так далее И вот
Лови себя только на одном как я отношусь
к
дискомфорту и Чем круче Ты развился тем
проще ты относишься к дискомфорту а
самое интересное Чем проще ты относишься
к дискомфорту Значит у тебя меньше
слабых мест соответственно у тебя меньше
проблем Поэтому вот Возьмите Я думаю
надеюсь что хоро хороший лайфхак надо
следить только за одним показателем
только за одним показателем и всё ведь
суть любого вашего развития на самом
деле в этом и заключается поэтому друзья
спокойствия уровень спокойствия а
уровень спокойствия оно появляется как
ки от что ты легко воспринимаешь
дискомфорт ты легко воспринимаешь потери
ты легко воспринимаешь то проблемы
которые стоят на пути к твоим целям Ну
препятствия более того ты даже эти
препятствия начинаешь где-то любить
Потому что они являются источником
твоего развития ты начинаешь любить свои
ошибки потому что они тоже являются
источником твоего развития А это
представляете Ты должен до какого уровня
дойти чтобы перейти к этому А когда ты
любишь ошибки Ты любишь препятствия
они имеют свойство как и любые проблемы
убегать от тебя Угу Потому что когда ты
любишь проблемы и препятствия они от
тебя убегают интересна такая вещь
поэтому проблема же в чём когда ты
боишься препятствии Боишься проблем они
те за тобой как будто гоняются они
становятся ещё хуже ещё больше это
свойство страха он только растёт тебя
чтобы напугать а зачастую 90 может быть
больше процентов наших страхов - это
вымышленный
и
поэтому я считаю один из Я не претендую
на истину в последней инстанции Но это
то чем я руководствуюсь то насколько я
преодолевают вот если заметили во всех
путешествиях то я то с парашютом прыгаю
то самого высокого моста в мире Стар
занки прыгнул сейчас в редженера я
прыгнул там на с горы на
дельтаплане для чего меня спрашивают
зачем вы рискуете жизнью Я говорю Да нет
я же считаю статистику я читаю а но для
меня важно такое статистика - это мозг
говорит ну вероятность такая-то всё
просто просчитал но после этого нужно а
преодолеть себя я говорю я пытаюсь
научить бояться Мы не перестанем никогда
но превратить в привычку преодоления
страха это можно превратить в привычку и
самое интересное Каждый раз когда ты
преодолевает страх потом Кай
так вот для того чтобы получать кайф от
жизни преодолевай свой страх и
дискомфорт и на этой весёлой ноте мы
заканчиваем Моха про сообщество
Спасибо что вы с нами нажимайте лайки
колокольчики комменты шерь этот выпуск и
надеюсь что этот выпуск принесёт вам
пользу Спасибо СБО СБО болье